enfin un chanteur qui ne perd pas la
voix sous le coup des honneurs officiels
c'est en chantant que charles trenet
notre fou chantant de 69 ans a remercié
ce matin le ministre de la culture de le
décoré des insignes de commandeur des
arts et des lettres
georges bégoux était là sans chantait
charles trenet j'ai la joie et le
bonheur de vous faire aujourd'hui
commandeur des arts et des lettres
comment recevez-vous les honneurs eh
bien je les reçois avec joie mais ça me
surprend d'autant plus que je n'étais
pas habitué à ce genre d'honneur
j'avais déjà l'amitié du public ce jeu
pour contenter
mais si on y ajoute
les barques officielle d'un gouvernement
reconnaissant oui à sa mort et ça me
fait plaisir
lorsque jack lang dit que vous êtes un
révolutionnaire vous reconnaissez vous
dans cette définition
certainement oui bien sûr parce que
avant que je débuts dans la chanson la
chanson nadal n'avait pas la même forme
donc évidemment ça a été une révolution
mais une révolution dans la chanson
c'est tout on peut s'attendre à un grand
retour puisque c'est la période des
grands retours des chanteurs
actuellement savez un retour sur la
scène à paris on me le reprochera et
parce que j'ai déjà fait mes adieux je
les ai faits pour des raisons très
sentimental parce que je voulais que ma
mère avant sa disparition nous fois et
elle match alors il n'est pas question
que je remonte sur scène mais la
télévision c'est magnifique
j'aimerais bien réaliser des spectacles
à la télévision avec de nouveaux
chanteurs vous avez encore beaucoup de
chansons nouvelles dans votre chapeau
qu'on ne connaît pas énormément car il
ya des chansons que j'ai fait il y a une
vingtaine d'années et que j'ai pas
encore eu le temps d'enregistrer
en ce mardi matin je chante sur les
femmes 1
j'arpente les fermiers et les châteaux
un fantôme qui chante montons femme que
non et je touche la nuit sur l'air des
proies des mouches ne peut pique pas non
non non je suis heureux
ça va aller plus loin et ça je m'en fous
à